ah bravo maintien et ans qu'est ce que
tu chantes bien à elles mêmes ces
chansons là tu veux être champion comme
ton papa oui oui oui voilà bon dis-moi
dis-moi tu veux pas de comédiens comme
ton grand père fernand a tué tous ces
comédiens
alors écoute je vais te donner un petit
conseil un petite confidence il a tu vas
t'asseoir là bas je me faire une petite
un petit cadeau la regarde
à nous de bien approche écoute voilà
c'est très facile comprendra bien il
faut comment dirais-je il faut avoir
coûte que coûte avoir mon nom ça ce
n'est rien mais d'abord franchement
avant tout as tu peur de paraître en
public dès ce soir on répondrait pour la
vérité oh oui la peur
déjà c'est un artiste incompris c'est
bon ça c'est très bon mais tout de même
attention comprendra bien ce n'est
qu'une précaution soit agité nerveux et
soit le follement mes dents alors
seulement là tu ne risques rien c'est
pour te soulager
ça c'est pour toi mais n'oublie surtout
pas qu'il faut cesser de l'être en face
du danger que le public ne voit jamais
ta mémoire indécise le souci d'être bon
la peur d'être mauvais désespoir les
plus grands et craintes les plus folles
et quand on a frappé quand le rideau
s'envole qu'il emporte avec lui tout
cela dans les frises en scène soit léger
soit 5 soit charmant surtout ne soit
jamais vulgaire ne soit pas trop
intelligent c'est inutile ne fait que
les choses faciles et n'accepte jamais
de rôles secondaires à ne joue jamais de
dos et chaque fois soit mieux il le faut
et maintenant un dernier mot adore son
métier c'est le plus beau du monde
le plaisir qu'ils te donne et déjà
précieux mais sa nécessité réelle est
plus profonde il apporte aux l'oubli des
chagrins et des mots et sa voiture c'est
encore mieux
c'est mieux que tous ces magnifiques et
tu verras tu verras ce que c'est qu'une
salle qui rit tu n'entendras ça c'est
unique mon chéri ans le bruit que ça
fait du gras comme c'est beau imagine un
très grand silence on vient de lever le
rideau un silence
complet on l'entendrait voler un
imprésario et soudain tu viens de faire
une chose qui plaît
un geste inattendu comique et ça
commence sa commande d'un coup ça
commence d'un seul coup et voilà le
silence rompu qui vole en mille éclats
le public s'abandonne à l'immense rafale
qui grondait le secoue et le rire aux
canaux qui traversent la salle en porte
tous les chagrins aller sous 6 et les
mots et comprend bien ceci comprend que
c'est pour ça qu'ils viennent à ceux qui
font sourire
on ne dit pas merci je sais oui mais ça
ne fait rien soit ignorée va laisse la
gloire à ceux qui font pleurer
je sais bien qu'on dit d'eux qu'ils sont
les grands artistes mais tant pis ne
soit pas honoré on honore jamais que les
gens qui sont tristes soit 1 paillasse
un pitre un pantin que t'importe fait
rire le public dissipe son ennui et s'il
te méprise et oublie sitôt qu'il a
passées à porte va à alès le seul fait
rien on se souvient si mal de ceux qui
vous ont fait du bien mais peut-être
qu'un jour alors tu connaîtras ce
bonheur ignorer de la gloire éphémère ce
bonheur qu'on achète pas oui peut-être
qu'un jour tu seras populaire et sa
voiture
c'est presque aussi bon que l'amour
à